Mình đang thăm một đồ tim kiếm và cơ hội Indonesia thông báo đã tìm thấy nạn nhân đầu tiên
trong buồn dưới mấy bay atirul bốn mấy hai năm chăm tại tình Nam Sulawesi
Cô vi đó lực lượng trình năng cùng phát hiện nhiều mạnh vỡ của mấy bay giúp khoảng 4,000 vực sảy ra
thay nạt.
Chứ mấy bay atirul bốn mấy hai năm chăm zor hàng Indonesia Air Transforms Quót bận hành
Mất lạng vào ngày mấy bay thăm một khi đang bay đến Nam Sulawesi
Chứ mấy bay của tổng cộng mấy một người gồm tấm thình viên tổ bay và bác cán bộ
hàng hay và thủy sảm Indonesia đang làm nhé vụ.
Theo cơ quan cú hộ của gia Indonesia, các đổi tim kiếm nên được chia thành nhiều nhóm để tiếp cận
các vị trí khác nhau trên sử nối, nhưng giòn ngờ lớn, sân mù dày đặt và để hình nối cao chân trở
khiến việc cú hộ rất khó khăn.
Nhà chức trách Indonesia cho biết, công tất nhiều trang miền vụ tành nạn sẽ được tiến hành
nãy số khi hoàn tất hoạt động cú nạn.